لقد شاهدت الصور من
قائمة عقارات في ولاية إنديانا ، فقد لفتت انتباهي ، حيث
قام سمسار العقارات بوضع جلسة تصوير لحفلة السبعينيات
لهذا
المنزل المستوحى من فرانك لويد رايت والذي يبدو أنه كبسولة زمنية
من Fort Wayne ، لدى كريستينا
فيتزباتريك المزيد حول كيفية  أصبح الأمر
فيروسيًا ،
لا ، إنه سوق للمشترين عندما
يبذل السماسرة أقصى ما في وسعهم لبيع
350.000
عقار ، انتشرت قائمة عقارات في Fort Wayne
Indiana على موقع Tick Tock ، حيث
نظموا حرفيًا حفلة منزل أصيلة كاملة من السبعينيات ،
أيها الرجال هناك أشعث في
كل مكان تنظرون إليه  كانت هذه
المجموعة المخصصة لـ Shag التي التقطت صور
السبعينيات من بنات أفكار سمسار العقارات إيان
بارنهارت ،
الديكور الفني ، والأثاث كان كل
شيء كما لو لم يمسها ، لقد
بعتهم على الموديلات وسيارات الفوندو والعضلات
وقيعان الجرس حتى أن بارنهارت دخلت
في  عمل يمكنك
رؤيته هناك في Paisley Perfection ،
دائمًا ما أمتلك شعر في الوجه ، لذا كان من السهل جدًا
بالنسبة لي أن أذهب إلى بعض الفتيات اللواتي يقطعن لحم
الضأن  صديقة تينا
ثلج ، زوجان منهم صديقان منذ فترة طويلة ،
هذه ليست المرة الأولى التي ينتشر فيها منزل Fort
Wayne بشكل فيروسي ، تحقق من
اللون الأرجواني الوردي والفيروزي Shag في هذا
المنزل الذي تم بيعه في عام 2020. قامت العائلة التي
اشترتها بالتقاط صورة في السبعينيات إلى
احتفل بهذه المناسبة ، فماذا عن
Fort Wayne في السبعينيات ، لقد حصلنا على كل شيء
من منتصف القرن الحديث حتى
السبعينيات من العمارة المعاصرة أعتقد أن
لدينا بعض الأحجار الكريمة هنا
ويقول بارنهارت إنه كان يأمل في
أن تصبح القائمة فيروسية لم يكن للتو '
نتوقع اهتمام
Nationwide بأن المنزل قد وصل إلى هذه النقطة ، فهو
موجود في السوق منذ يوم السبت الماضي فقط ،
لكن بارنهارت قال إن هناك
تدفقًا ثابتًا للاهتمام منذ ذلك الحين